this is Matt a Spinelli associate editor  at GameSpot and I'm here to show you  co-op gameplay from the ps4 version of  action RPG MMO hybrid Marvel heroes  Omega the game originally launched as  Marvel heroes on PC in 2013 but it's  latest iteration is now coming to  consoles with the ability to play with a  friend locally the added functionality  is a welcome feature that'll be sure to  please all of you Marvel Ultimate  Alliance fans out there do you still  enjoy couch co-op games let us know in  the comments below and while you're here  give us a thumbs up and subscribe to our  YouTube channel for more coverage of  Marvel heroes Omega  good work taking down living laser no  wonder fury speaks so highly of you  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  that should keep the rest of the cells  locked up tight I just wish you could  have gotten here  oh look it's time to play  check out my toys  fall down already  you  [Music]  it's not over also your action figure  sucks  [Music]